- I think a condiment's job is to make
everything that you're
eating taste better.
If it doesn't elevate, then why add it?
(suave music)
- Jufran Banana Sauce?
Why is it red?
- That makes no sense.
- Smells like ketchup.
It smells nothing like bananas.
- This label is lying to me.
- Is this sauce that's made from bananas?
Or is it sauce for bananas?
- It says shake well...
- Oh, yeah.
- Wow.
- It's a little bit sweeter than ketchup.
- On the way to barbecue sauce,
but then took a left at banana grove.
- This would be good on chicken fingers.
- I feel like if you were drunk
you wouldn't know that
it wasn't ketchup, maybe.
- What's there to say? It's good!
- Harissa Spread.
Ugh.
Oh.
- What are you?
- Uh oh, it smells like it might be spicy.
- This is really good. It's very tangy.
- This would be really good on pasta.
- Or a ciabatta.
- I hated it at first bite,
and now it's dancing in my
pallet, and all I want is more.
- [Voiceover] Sambal
Terasi Condement Sauce.
- It smells like the spiciest
chili at the chili cook off.
- There's shrimp in here!
- Let's see what this is like.
- Before the spice kicks in,
I just want to say it tastes pretty good.
- I'm pretty impressed with how much
of my mouth it's already affected.
(grunts)
- I think you could put it on rice,
maybe a nice stir fry.
- Whenever heat stuff gets to a certain
heat level it doesn't have flavor anymore.
- There are two ingredients
in salted shrimp:
one is shrimp, the other is salt.
- Look at their little shrimpy eyes.
- Oh god, it smells exactly
like you'd think it'd smell.
- Confirmation that the little
black spots are their eyes.
- I don't want to eat this.
- No.
- Oh my god, there's so much salt on it.
- 40% of your daily sodium
is in here 33 times.
- It would be good on
things that need salt.
- How does this qualify as a condiment?
- So this is Fermented Bean Curd.
Bean curd is great, it's tofu, its soy.
This is disgusting.
- At least this didn't
crawl around at some point.
(yells)
- What the?
(gags)
- Nope.
- Smells very sweet, oh god.
- Look at this thing.
(groans)
(laughs)
- Oh god, that is
literally the worst thing
I've ever tasted in my life.
- Coating my mouth in this salty slime.
- I'm gonna have to date,
get married, have children
and that taste is gonna be in my mouth.
- I might be allergic to that.
- What do you do with this?
- This would go good on
a viking funeral boat
that you put out into the ocean
and then shoot a flaming arrow toward.
- There are probably
people that love this.
- Everybody's got a
different tongue, right?
Cute snack.
(mutters)
I'm just a tiny baby
shrimp, I'm covered in salt,
so if you're hungry, and you're
tired of being well-hydrated, come at me!
It's pretty good, though.